and now Chester a-bomb would wish to
respond to the controversial joke that
was made in last week's Family Guy
episode I meant angry I just
disappointed
there is a joke that many of you have
heard in family game this week Oh joke
pet most likely the majority of you just
sort of missed didn't think it all about
but some of us found very very offensive
certain political figures have gotten in
on this controversy they found it in
porn
honey that's right you know mister so
many people petitions have already
voiced their opinion in fact this week
this is what you had to say about it
this world is full of cruel cold hearted
people who would do such a thing
this guy MacFarlane who did this is a
hater makes a lot of money for Fox but I
think there should be some standards
when is enough enough I don't care if
you hate the media even though you try
to use it to your advantage
second day you can this is it outright
because of this I have decided to hire
an attorney that's right I decided to
work for free because he didn't want to
go after Fox for a while this is my
attorney let's submit him and he is
quote these things to say to the Fox
Network mistress venom the Fox
corporation thinks that they have done
absolutely nothing illegal what do you
say about that wrong so wrong under
Section 37b of the United States
Copyright Act of 1976 signed by them it
states quite clearly that all offer
shall become null and void in and you
can write it in this photostatic copy i
the undersigned shall forfeit all rights
privileges and licenses here in and here
in contain etc etc facts medicine City
employer common etc etc memo B's boonie
tart
it's all there black and white clear as
crystal
you stole fizzy lifting drinks you know
everything do it sure I mean you stole
this man's junk you bumped into his
comedic derriere which has to be
sterilized and watched so you get
nothing
good day sir when that all sounds very
impressive
yes but nowhere near as impressive as
our settlement will be for if the courts
rule in our favor and they will then we
shall receive a box wait what
that's it all of this legal posturing
for a box
nu nu 2 nu e furnish box
how about here good day sir if I said
good day um I guess I'm going to be
looking for another new attorney so all
I have to say to you be my family guy is
you really knew who I am that's so cool
watch me all the time
I will have my box this is Jimmy boom
see justice justice come on